well if you plan on going to church for
christmas you might want to make those
plans here pretty soon places of worship
are adapting their services this year
because of coveted restrictions bianca
holman is live for us this morning with
those details hi bianca
hey good morning alex church's moss
temples
they all can hold 25 percent of their
fire code capacity that's a change from
what it was before
now most churches are requiring
reservations so they can accommodate
people and keep people safe matter of
fact you can see the catholic church
behind me has their mass service times
already posted
for the christmas eve and sunday service
some congregations are moving their
christmas eve services entirely online
while others are offering more services
to
ensure safety precautions are met the
bishop of diocese says they have
openings available
at parishes across the valley but
they're filling up quickly
it's a sign folks are looking for
spiritual guidance and comfort
well i think the message across the
whole country is going to be
have faith the lord is going to see us
through
one of the 10th century saints said god
is closer to us than we are to ourselves
and i think it's just a cause to be
hopeful and
faith-filled and optimistic that we're
going to get through this
and if you plan to attend a church
service check the organization's website
or call
times may be adjusted to accommodate the
increase in
attendance now most are having us
both they could have in person and
virtual services because of course if
you don't feel comfortable being
outside you can of course watch the
service from the comfort of your home
reporting live from near cathedral way
and las vegas boulevard bianca holman 8
news now